über sänger dann für ihn für diese
freundliche und kurze vorstellung
ich danke vor allem dollar sehr für die
einladung und ab heute morgen noch mal
von spiel ich brauche immer wieder sagen
wir herumzufahren merke da schon das aus
worten bewegung im briefwechsel mit
einem kollegen eine gang und herren
kollegen aus den nachbarn zu ziehen
da ich mich vor wenigen tagen veranlasst
dass in einer festrede zum gedenken an
wilhelm von humboldts geburt vor 250
jahren zum ausdruck gebrachte los und
westen abhandlung über den geist der
menschheit zu retten
ich hatte ausgeführt der junge autor
dieser unerhörten schrift aus dem jahre
1797 habe gute gründe dafür gehabt seine
einsichten nicht in eine phänomenologie
des geistes sondern im universal
angelegte studien über den geist der
sprache münchen zu lassen und damit dem
studium des menschlichen geistes ein
gänzlich neues forschungsfeld zu
erstellen war nicht der seitenblick auf
hegel der den berliner
kulturwissenschaftler schaftler zu
seiner kritische nachfrage brachte
sondern die tatsache dass heute
überhaupt noch mit einer formel die der
vom geist der sprache ein sind verbunden
wird
ich dachte zunächst kollege verstehe
nicht wie man in zeiten der leib und
hören versessenheit überhaupt nur vom
geist welche können führte ihn in meiner
antwort vor wie selbstverständlich hier
immer noch vom geist sprechen wenn uns
etwas das ist wichtig
erläutern wenn uns etwas als ganzes im
ganzen so bewegten
das ist uns belebt und wittert damit
glaubt ihr ich den verbreitet die
zweifel an der angeblichen reinen
intellektualität des geistes aus
geworben zu haben
doch der entwicklung konnte ich
entnehmen dass es nicht um ein
bedenklich
die derzeit gegen die freiheit und
andere verdächtige formeln und formen
des bewusstseins vorgebracht wird der
stein des anstoßes offenen meer der
vermeintlichen sozialismus der in der
übertragung eines in der
selbstwahrnehmung des menschen leicht
noch gerade gerechtfertigten ausdrucks
auf ein rein äußerlich es vorkommen
die diesen einwand wird offenkundig
schon die sprache als äußerlich
begriffen wie jemand das nur denken kann
der sich immerhin in der lage sind mit
der kritik am sogenannten essentiell is
muss einen sinn zu verbinden ist mir
rätselhaft denn schon was sprache
versteht einen nur sofern er selbst zu
sprechen versteht sich somit welt und
das immer auch von innen her in der
sprache bewegt das gleiche gilt für die
kultur der begriff niemand auch nur im
ansatz erfassen kann
wer nicht erfahren hat was kultur für
den bedeutet der in ihr lebt und er
frech zudem davon ausgeschlossen
für den geist meine damen und herren die
das entsprechend so fassungslos man
gelegentlich auch es wenn man erleben
muss zu welcher geistlosigkeit als auch
diejenigen fähig sind den mann weil sie
menschen sind die geistlichkeit wieder
absprechen kann noch absprechen lassen
gleichwohl ist mir das ostentative
unverständnis gegenüber dem ganz großer
traum
es hat in den 80er jahren des
vergangenen jahrhunderts um
kannitverstan geführt dass die
einführung der kulturwissenschaften
erleichterte geist so war damals zu
hören und des zitierens nicht welche
verweilt würden den fußnoten stehen
könnte man schon deshalb nicht mehr
sagen weil der begriff einfluss von
nägel gesetzt sein
vom geist könne man sich daher nur
befreien immer nicht mehr von krise also
dürfen ford nicht länger von den
geisteswissenschaften sondern es müsse
nunmehr vom kulturwissenschaften
gekommen wie schwer es fällt ihm durch
vermeidung gekommen war unlängst zu
erkennen als ein wahrhaft geistloser
politiker im ganzen komplex der roman
sie tue und geisteswissenschaften
wahrhaftig welt oder die wahrheit fällt
ihm abgesprochen hatte
das mobilisierte insbesondere auch jene
kulturwissenschaftler die noch vor
wenigen jahren zuvor nicht das geringste
interesse an der wahrheitsfrage und erst
recht nicht an der mit ihr verknüpft
haftrichter auf zu trinken
jetzt aber verteilten sich mit der
versicherung
sie seien sehr wohl in der lage fakten
von fiktion zu unterscheiden und
erkannten sogar an dass in dieser
unterscheidung eine elementare ihr
bedingung ihrer wissenschaftlichen
arbeit live im jahr in meine damen und
herren liegt der essentiell ist muss auf
den keine wissenschaft verpflichtet dann
in der welt kehrt eben dieser
unterscheidung zwischen zutreffend und
nicht zu treffen zwischen gemeint oder
aber nicht gemeint liegt die elementare
kompetenz des guides und solange die
nicht als basiselemente sprechen zu
handeln und somit als notwendiges
momente verstehen von sprache und kultur
zum einsatz bringen können wissen wir
gar nicht was sprechen und handeln
überhaupt da was kommt im übrigen nicht
der geringste vorbehalt gegenüber den
begriff der kultur führende theoretiker
begeistert haben schon zu beginn gefragt
ist jahrhunderts mit guten gründen für
die ersetzung des begriffs der
geisteswissenschaften durch den der
kulturwissenschaften plädiert zufälliger
sein dass gerade zwei banker die jetzt
anschließenden vortrag hier behandelt
werden das dazu in deutschland voraus
unheiligen politischen und nicht
gekommen
bedauern wir und nachdem mit leider dann
doch so gekommen ist war es dann
durchaus gut dass sie die
kulturwissenschaften wenig neben den
geisteswissenschaften und namentlich
auch in opposition zur philosophie
etablieren konnten ich bin überzeugt
dass auch eingesehen und spielte neben
dem spät marktes durch angehauchten
tanzen idealismus und dem reiz durch die
angelsächsische kann
da ist auch die wachsende popularität
der werke matches eine rolle schon für
den jungen mit gesang und kultur
die höheren entgelten der geschichte im
gleichen gegend wurde keine tragende
rolle mehr supercup das hatte seinen
grund in dem an die hebel mechanismus
mit dem sie schon
hofbauer gefeiert hatte und den jakob
park war seine jungen vater kollegen
dauern so kommt der geist bei nietzsche
weder als historische prozent noch als
general bedingungen für den
korrespondieren und konstitutive
gebrauch der begriffe entsprechen und
handeln im blick wenn man schulmäßig mit
ihm umgehen wollte muss man sagen er ist
das großzügige 18 von der logischen
ordnungs leistung des geistes erlaubte
ihm im fortgesetzten selbst widerspruch
mit dem ball zu lieben der miete suchte
nach erkenntnis einzig und er suchte
auch nach wissen
gleichwohl verleugnete er und ausgesetzt
diese auch sachverhalte und allgemeines
verständnis bezogenen leistungen des
geistes alle rechte möglich dabei da er
alles andere als unlogisch
aber er mit raute allen auftrieb mädchen
setzen begründete blieben dafür die der
sprache der schule eben das geistige am
geist ausmacht dass dies möglich war
kann ich mir nur garbisch erklärender
frietsch unter keinen umständen in den
verdacht geraten wurde er könne sich
bloß für den ganz vielleicht sogar für
den reinen geist interessieren
seine zusagen darf methodische absicht
war dem geist in den zusammenhängen
aufzusuchen in denen er wahrgenommen
werden kann und auch dass conti für sich
bestreiten
wirksam ist die so ausgesetzt sind
nietzsches zahlreiche reflektion und
thesen auch seine auf scherz list und
rache vielen subtilen gegen den 1
für eine philosophie der geistreiche
autor spricht in seinem werk überaus
häufig kompakt und verwendet den
schillernden ausdruck für alles wofür
auch im alltäglichen sprechen
dieses wort verwendet wird im register
der tüte kritik edition für werk- und
makler ist der terminus weit mehr als
tausend mal etwa 1000 dreimal
ausgewiesen
wer das für beliebig hält möge sich an
die stilistischen vorbilder in eine
nische in der dritten spruchweisheit
humanistischen flori medien und der
europäischen bora liste vom und wenn die
lauer schukow bis hin zu mittag und
goethe erinnern und weiß damit zugleich
was ihre seiner schwester auf jeder
schuld nicht zufrieden auch in der
politik so außerordentlich ergiebig
macht die knappe zeit erlaubt nur wenige
beispiele zu bieten da wird es als
lächerlich bezeichnet einen gleich zwei
meter schmalen erscheinen zu lassen
das bereichen an krieg ein beispiel das
sie verbindet
es wird vom geist der griechen vom geist
der deutschen alle anderen völker aber
auch vom geist der wissenschaft der
musik von betfair starken und schwachen
und immer wieder vom geist der weiber
gesprochen es wird behauptet der mensch
egal sei arm ohne eitelkeit oder es wird
in einer anschaulichen überlegung
vorgeführt dass man nichts geist wird
oder einen bezug auf etwas körperliches
bedeuten können das körperliche die
tiere gibt die hand aber ab mit der man
den ball zu fassen wird
und denen die die wie auch in der
konferenz nach einem genaueren
verständnis des geistes suchen wird
entgegengehalten zitat der hat keinen
geist becher teamgeist sucht
nur kleine erinnerung am morgen so geht
es in unterhalb der mann ist sehr sie
sich auf soziale durch weckt aber hände
und allemal gehen eigentlich wichtig
töten des anbietens breites verständnis
geist des geistes gerichteter weise wäre
teil seinem geistig ausgreifenden
vortrag würde man die gehaltvollen
vielfalt der populistischen großansicht
wird menschlich allzumenschlichen
porträt des geistes dass peaches in
bemerkenswerter konsequenz zwischen im
ersten arbeiten doch vorstudie zur
geburt der tragödie aus dem geist der
musik bis hin zu sexy homo einwirft
wenig sind ausschließen
aber da ich mich gern hier noch nicht
einmal versuchen kann ohne das zweite
gepard zu überschreiten befriedige ich
meinen schulen treffen an einer theorie
des geistes und hebel mit weniger
werbung einige systematisch aspekte
dieses kaleidoskop des geistes hervor
die mir mit ihm
wer nach protektiven mit überwiegend hin
auszuweiten scheinen fünf punkte
da ist erstens peaches überzeugung von
der unerlässlichen verpackungsgröße ein
ausdruck den er selbst gebrauch der
geist braucht mindestens ein medium in
und an dem er kennt licher und ohne dass
er auch gar nicht erst zu senken
die der jüngsten markt sprach analytisch
angestrengten debatte über faktor um des
bewusstseins würden ihn als einen auf
einer gedanken
rosen verkehrung hervor wie
missverständnis weil er den körper als
er ziemlicher frühere erfasst bewusst
seiner geistigen ihn als stets nur
körperlich eingebettete ausdrucksformen
des leibes combo von bewusst werden und
geist kann auch nur gesprochen werden
oder wenn überhaupt von gross seinen
geist gesprochen wird wird bereits der
entzündliche vergegenwärtigung in einer
organischen einkleidung vorausgesetzt
zweitens ist da
mit der verkörperung des geistes
großräumig verbundene überzeugung dass
der geist zur natur und zum leben in
nietzsches vokabular somit wesentlich
auch zum leib gehören auch darin ist
eine philosophische
selbstverständlichkeit zu sehen solange
man einen so weiten natur betritt
unterstellt es zu erkennen gibt wieder
zurechnung des geistes zum leben wendet
er sich gegen jede form der krampf in
der intensivierung des geistes die er
leider nicht mit der erforderlichen
schärfe von arbeitsteiligen
vorstellungen abgrenzt wie sie etwa in
der krankenzahlen rollenverteilung
zwischen einen erfahrungsschatz von
natur und analogen dialektes oder
spontan atmen leist und des geistes
unterschieden sind können auch sie
trifft sein akku den er gegen alles
richtet was ihm schon von fern wie ein
aktueller physische tourismus aus dass
eine 550 unterscheidung man kann eben
auch und continental
ohne dame schon eine ganz bestimmte form
und wetter zu sichten bekanntlich steht
nicht schön sogar paaren und kann unter
einem anti metaphysischen fördern
die tatsache dass es auch funktionale
oder was wir ja genau wissen müsste
perspektivische konstruktionen einer
unterscheidung für die beliebten und
nominalen zugang zur welt des erkennens
und des handels leben kann erkennt er in
ihren methodologische neigen wird erst
gar nicht an
und so lässt er seine therapie gegen die
hinterwäldler predigen ohne seinen
prophetischen weltweiten vor den fatalen
eindruck zu bewahren dass er selbst
offenbar viel zu lange auf dem berg
hinter den wäldern zu gebracht hat und
offenbar hat nietzsches es seine eigene
lektüre von kants kritik der usa zu
profitieren leute zu früh abgebrochen um
zu wissen dass eine unterscheidung zu
sensibel des bundes in kreativen ist
nicht mit einem wechsel zu verwechseln
denn im zweiten teil der dritte kritik
werde werden beide perspektiven zu einem
begriff des lebens verbunden der die
bedingung dafür dass die menschen zu den
markantesten formen in seinem kleinen
mund legt gehört die rede von der großen
vernunft des leibes in ihr kann man die
dritte eigenart seiner geist konzeption
namhaft noch im bleibt eine einheit
in allen seinen äußerungen wirkende
kraft unterstellt von der etwa nicht
teilt das sie durchgängig geistigkeit
oder aber dass die schlüssel und als
verstand vernunft und bewusstsein der
standard insofern kann der light als
träger dessen angesehen werden dass mir
ebenfalls als gut bezeichnet
aber leben wenn man sie dann zu stellen
hinzufügen auch bei ihm schritt
eigentlich aus als geist begleitet wird
ist die bei gleichen der philosophische
bedeutung der rede von der großen
vernunft des leibes steht jedenfalls für
mich ganz außer frage
dazu hat auch an verschiedenen stellen
einiges gesagt aber man darf auch die
mängel nicht übersehen die mit dem
einsatz dieser formel bei nietzsche
verbunden sind bewusst sein verstand und
vernunft stehen unter der alleinigen
verfügung des leibes der sie zur
steigerung seiner lebenskräfte dort muss
kosten wieder von der schreibung seiner
not zum einsatz setzt und ich bin
agenten des leibes den sie nicht nur
bezeichnen und zum ausdruck bringen
sie gehen wer gefallen an seinem
gängelband also sozusagen an der und
alleine in dieser bezeichnen muss so
meine ich diesen monolog des leibes wird
die spezifische leistung bewusst klein
grund nicht verkaufen
denn werden leistung besteht wesentlich
leistungsbewusstsein versteht
wesentlichen der vermittlung die das
soziale nebeneinander und miteinander
verschiedener leiber pflicht uns selbst
und
ich könnte nicht nur die liebe des
leides befriedigen wie immer wieder
betont wird
sie können auch die welt bewegungen der
veränderten und erlauben ihm erst mit
seinesgleichen im gemeinschaft aber eben
auch in erklärte nun frieden zu leben
dieses große vernunft des leibes werden
somit ein vollkommen verfehlt das modell
begleitetes geistes denn von ihm bliebe
bestenfalls ein asoziales sind vermögen
zur bestmöglichen übereinstimmung des
leibes münchen setzt vom geist erwartet
aber gerade auch nietzsche eine
verbindende leistung im kulturellen
zusammenhang damit wird fußball formel
matches eigenen ansprüchen nicht gerecht
hinzu kommt dass auch nietzsches natur
auffassung nicht gerecht wird nicht
entsprechen deren größe besteht nämlich
darin dass sie weit davon entfernt
parodistisch zu sagen dass bei einer von
uns vielleicht unterstellen möchte die
natur ist gegensätzlich erfahrt ihr
entstammten tragische verfassung des
menschlichen sieht sich auf jeder stufe
des leiters aber eben auch auf der der
menschlichen kultur entfaltete wenn ihr
also der rede von der großen trends des
leidens einem film erhalten wollen etwa
dem dass sie auch mit dem inneren
gegensätzen des leibes zu geben vermag
das wäre eine mögliche bedeutung muss
sie in der lage sein die
gesellschaftlichen gegensätze zwischen
begleiter zu vermitteln an vierter
stelle
füge ich nun an das mädchen unmittelbar
nach abschluss von also sprach
zarathustra die mono logische
beschränkung seiner bewusstseins
konzeption durch ein gegenmodell
kontaktiert dass er dem nachfolgenden
schriften leider nicht mehr
wenn sie das schreiben haben dann können
sie uns das was man tragen und zu
platzieren 15 deutsche wissenschaft
fünftes buch also nachdem cera tusk noch
hinzu gesetzt und dann leider unter dem
zeitdruck unter dem die gelangen die
letzten beiden jahren meines schreibens
gehen nicht mehr wieder aufgenommen nach
meinem urteil ist in dieser
unscheinbaren neukonzeption seiner
bewusstseins theorien der bedeutendste
beitrag matches zur philosophie jedes
teil uns überhaupt zu sehen
da ich ihn hier nicht mehr aufhören kann
beschränke ich mich auf keinen einzigen
täter nur kurze gebete league
kommentieren
auf eben jene macoris muss dass wir
künftig des fünften buches wir könnten
wissenschaft da heißt es lapidar aussage
nochmal der ist 1886 geschrieben und
nicht etwa nach gründung der digitalen
kommunikation
der satz lautet bewusstsein ist
eigentlich nur ein verbindung netz
zwischen menschen nur als solches hat es
das bewusstsein nicht entwickeln müssen
die stadt gesetzt das bewusstsein also
so viel wie zur begründung im zoo muss
bei der mensch als das gefährdete tier
und schutz durch seinesgleichen
benötigte als soziale hier brauchte er
in ganz anderer weise als andere tiere
seines gleichen das ganze leben die
durch nicht nur sozusagen in der
anfangszeit des wachstums er musste
seine not und gäste verpflichtet
sie hören dass ich weder zitieren er
musste seine note aufzudrücken wissen
musste sich verständlich zu machen
wissen zudem allen hat er zuerst bewusst
für ein möglicher musste also selbst
noch einmal wissen was ihm fehlt musste
wissen wie es ihm zugute ist und musste
schließlich wisse denn selbst wer nur
eine oberflächliche kenntnis von
nietzsches schriften hat wird
augenblicklich erkennen wie ungeheuer
die kehrtwende ist wie der autor hier
folgten hier so gut wie alle seinen
schriften verbirgt nietzsche wissen und
wahrheit und mit der these vom
bewusstsein als ein die ganze gattung
umfassendes netz gleichermaßen erklärt
er wie hingegen beide als unumgänglich
wissen und sein
für die augenblicklich mit jedem buch
genau genommen bereits mit jedem
gedanken und universalen at gegebenen
als lebensnotwendig angesehenen auch das
ein ausdruck dieses mitteilungs zeichen
muss es nicht nur ein bisschen von deren
bedeutung von ihren möglichen effekten
von ihrer logischen und sachlichen
stimmigkeit sondern eben auch von ihrer
wahrheit im hinblick auf die verwendung
des jeweiligen bedeutungs konzept und
kontextes team nicht im sinne ist einer
mit der musischen vielleicht perfekte
kind gottes abhängigen wahrheit davon
aber von der übereinstimmung der
mitteilung zeichen miteinander und im
gebrauch mit dem die andere sie
gebrochen
das ist für ihn hier mit einem mal eine
notwendigkeit
wer kann niemand wenn er nicht von
unerfüllbaren väter mit der physischen
hoffnungen ausgeht
wer dort wohnen es ist somit das die
menschheit als ganzer umfassende
sprechen und dentin juni in der
gemeinsamen bewältigung des lebens das
hat so etwas wie ein erlebnis das ich
ihm aus der nische tiere mit teil der
geist ist dass die menschheit als ganzes
umfassende sprechen und denken im
dienste der gemeinsamen der welt punkte
zulegen
der geist fast alles was wir mitteilung
durch ausdruck teichen im dienst der
verständigung mit seinesgleichen
kenntlich machen kann und das in diese
leistung zu nicht unerheblichen teilen
auf welches etwa diesem hintergrund
dieser revision seinen anspruch auf
witten und wahrheit mit ausschließen im
august sein theorie wird die
besonderheit des letzten und gewiss
bemerkenswerteste punktes der guide
konstruktion könne nie zuvor darauf
bezieht sich meine fünfte und mit
äußerster verkürzung abschließende
bemerkung der philosoph der ganzes werk
durch nicht müde wird die freiheit uns
menschen in abrede zu stellen wieder
ideal kleines leben und dass alle
anderen menschen auf die in ihm ankommt
darin ein freier geist zusammen
es ist bekannt aber wieso seid
menschlich allzumenschliches mit dem
aufgeklärten die alte liebe ein
persönliches fiel auch beim schreiben
denken und schaffen wir immer diese
proklamiert die freundliche
wissenschaftlich zu erkennen dass auch
sie für sich was er hier auch diese
freien geld für sich selbst als
verbindliches ideal konzipiert und mit
dem wichtigsten aphorismen buch nach dem
fahrrad war also im jenseits von gut und
böse wird deutlich dass hier nicht nur
für alle und keinem argumentiert
vielmehr setzt er ein existenzielles
bemühen in die eigene selbstüberwindung
als freier geist
das kann man so verstehen wir die
transformation heute verstehen der sache
vorher noch feiertag wird wenn
überwindet er die hessen in der es heißt
nicht mehr absolut nichts verschwindet
er bleibt gerade in der selbst dieser
bildung dazu mit der betroffenheit
insofern gibt es eine kontinuität als
freier platz die dramatik hoffen sie
sehen das ist beträchtlich
nicht nur weil sie immer wieder beteuert
dass das kleine freiheit gibt sondern
weil er sich zumindest ohne
ausgesprochen nunmehr auch in seiner
these vom august
einheiten verbindungsnetz zwischen
mensch und mensch messen lassen muss
hier kann das individuum nur die rolle
einer denkt man das mit seines kloten
zwischen den jeweiligen feldern des
netzes in welt umspannende kommunikation
einnehmen
dass alle mit allen möglich oder jeden
mit allen anderen können nun muss es
aber bereits als tragisch gesichert
individuum überhaupt unter den anspruch
eine existenz selbstüberwindung zu
stellen
gleichwohl ist nietzsche in keiner
anderen phase seines denkens der
konzeption des geistes mehr als den
abriss
er hat erstmals ermöglicht es einer
globalen dynamik und der nächste
auftritt globalen institution der
verständigung aller menschen und
versucht in anerkennung der impliziten
universalität der gleichermaßen sensibel
wie intellektuellen produktivität der
ganzen gattung kleinen renaissance ismus
auf die spitze der individualität zu
treiben um eine philosophie der zukunft
und ihren geist das überleben der
menschheit in freiheit möglich zu machen
wer für eine philosophische fand also
die anti die bereich an ihren inneren
widersprüchen zu grunde gehen muss der
muss auch ganz geistvolle rede von der
menschheit in der person eines sieben
menschen ins reich der fabel verwiesen
und er sollte zur kenntnis nimmt zu
welcher form
der geist hier bei nietzsche wenn wir es
analysieren
auch wenn ganz und gar auf die
individualität und die freiheiten stellt
muss er als dass alle verbindende humane
bewusstsein begriffen werden das nach
art eine institution zu denken ist und
darin trotz aller die erforderten
produktiven gegensätze vor allem bildung
gegenseitiges verstehen und eine
künstlerische entfaltung der kultur
verlangten der mensch in seiner
gegenwart wenn der mensch hat sein wenn
der mensch in seiner gegenwart aufgehen
und gerade bergen ein exempel für die
zukunft setzen kann
wie war ein denker des 19 jahrhunderts
und wilhelm von humboldts näher als
dieser nach selbstüberwindung verlangen
teure feature das wissen von der krise
und genehmigt die bemerkung vom anfang
von empfänger auch ohne kruste wie sie
ihre vorbemerkung enten das wissen von
der krise halten wir vor allem richtet
mit besonderer dringlichkeit